schützengräben und zerstörung
erschreckende bilder und das alles
mitten in europa russland setzt seine
offensive in der ukraine fort und das
zunehmend brutaler immer öfter werden
inzwischen auch zivilisten zur
zielscheibe russischer geschosse läufer
werden verletzt oder getötet
feuerpausen für flucht korridore sind
schon mehrfach gescheitert
willkommen zum zdf spezial nach heftigem
beschuss in der nacht sind die kämpfe
auch tagsüber weiter gegangen
zum dritten mal haben sich am nachmittag
ukrainische und russische unterhändler
getroffen us-präsident beiden hat sich
vor wenigen stunden mit den
regierungschefs von deutschland
frankreich und großbritannien abgestimmt
nach angaben der vereinten nationen sind
mittlerweile mehr als 1,7 millionen
menschen aus der ukraine geflohen mehr
als die hälfte ins benachbarte polen was
wir über das kampfgeschehen in der
ukraine wissen fasst matthias kugel
zusammen
gewehrschüsse gegen gefahr von oben
während hunderte in todesangst fliehen
die apokalyptischen bilder aus der stadt
in knapp 30 kilometer nordwestlich von
kiew stehen symbolisch für die lage der
ukraine an tag 12 der russischen
invasion
immer mehr städte stehen unter
russischem feuer hunderttausende
zivilisten warten auf evakuierung weil
sich russland und die ukraine uneins
sind über den verlauf von flugkorridoren
der kreml fordert dass sie nach russland
und belarus führen kiew fordert sichere
wege in den westen
so sind unzählige ukraine weiter den
russischen bomben ausgeliefert waren aus
in schutzräumen oder suchen trost im
gebet
trotz anhaltender angriffe es gibt auch
gespräche am morgen zeigt sich der
ukrainische präsidentenberater podolczak
vor einem hubschrauber der ihn zur
dritten verhandlungsrunde mit russischen
vertretern nach belarus bringen soll
unklar zur stunde mit welchen
ergebnissen und ob es eine tragbare
lösung für humanitäre flugkorridore aus
den kampfgebieten geben wird
international bringt sich der nato staat
türkei als vermittler ins spiel der
türkische aussenminister twittert dass
der russische und ukrainische
aussenminister entschieden hätten sich
am donnerstag in der türkei zu einem
dreiergespräch mit ihm zu treffen
eiserne beistands bekundungen für putin
dagegen aus china
egal wie tückisch der internationale
sturm ist china und russland werden ihre
strategische entschlossenheit
aufrechterhalten und die umfassende
kooperative partnerschaft in der neuen
ära vorantreiben die freundschaft
zwischen beiden völkern ist felsenfest
die sanktionen des westens gegen
russland würden nur neue probleme
schaffen und gefährdeten eine politische
lösung so die pekinger lesart trotzdem
sei man bereit zu vermitteln in kiew
fürchten die menschen jederzeit einen
großangriff die millionenstadt gilt als
fast vollständig eingekesselt von
russischen truppen
freiwillige kämpfer und sanitäter aus
dem ausland machen sich auf den weg an
die front um die ukrainischen truppen in
den schützengräben um kiew zu
unterstützen unklar was genau hier auf
diese jungen männer zukommt die bereit
sind für die ukraine ihr leben zu
riskieren und
zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt der ehemalige
bundeswehr general egon ramms wer uns
seit dem angriff russlands immer wieder
hilft die lage einzuschätzen guten abend
und
neunhof es sollte zeitlich begrenzte
feuerpausen geben um zivilisten aus
mehreren städten an sicheren fluchtweg
zu ermöglichen warum hat das nicht
funktioniert
weil offensichtlich die koordinierung
zwischen diesen sachen direkt vor ort
nicht richtig funktioniert hat man muss
sich dann die frage stellen
weil das möglicherweise von einer seite
so beabsichtigt wenn ja könnte dass nur
russland sein da die ukrainischen
soldaten die ukrainische kämpfer
sicherlich interesse daran haben dass
ihre familien in sicherheit gebracht
werden können kurze anmerkung zu dem
thema der flugkorridore nachgeordnete
russland die würden dann möglicherweise
oder belarus die würden dann
möglicherweise funktionieren und damit
könnte russland sich gegenüber der welt
als ich sagen dass mal der helfer der
zivilen bevölkerung der ukraine
darstellen wobei ich diese möglichkeit
als eine sehr schlechte beurteilungen
nicht glaube dass ukrainer ukraine
stämmige bürger aus diesen bereichen
diese korridore zu tun so sieht das aus
schauen wir noch mal auf das große bild
wie entwickelt sich dieser krieg nach
ihren informationen
also nach dem was mir im augenblick
bekannt ist und nach der auswertung der
informationen die weitgehende auch ihm
zur verfügung stehen sieht es so aus
dass die russen ihre position gefestigt
haben aber nach wie vor wenn sie
vordringen nur relativ langsam
vordringen das heißt das ganze was man
vorgehabt hat auf einer sehr schnellen
zeitachse zu realisieren gelingt
offensichtlich nicht es bleibt
abzuwarten wie weit russland in der lage
ist frische kräfte möglicherweise aus
weißrussland herbeizuführen und dann im
angriff so sage ich das jetzt mit den
militärischen worten wieder schwung zu
geben nach wie vor ist für mich wirklich
herausragend der verteidigungsstellung
die kampfmoral der ukrainische
streitkräfte einschließlich der was ich
mal eine bürgerwehr nennen würde sich
dort auch entsprechend gewartet hat die
bundesregierung prüft jetzt weitere
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine dazu
gab es heute eine massive bedrohung aus
dem russischen außenministerium gegen
nato länder wie riskant sind
waffenlieferungen in dieser zeit
also das ist jetzt eine unterschiedliche
auffassung so will ich mal sagen
zwischen uns auf der einen seite das als
nato durch deutschland und eu
gegenüber russland für russlands diese
waffenlieferung an die ukrainischen
streitkräfte demokratischen freiwilligen
ein dorn im auge weil russland
sicherlich das ziel hat die japanischen
streitkräfte mit blick auf waffen und
munition auszuhungern und dann auf diese
art und weise besser vormarschieren zu
können und zu versuchen einen sieg zu
erringen durch diese waffen liefert
praktisch die ukrainische armee ständig
weiter unterstützt und bleibt damit kann
fähig und die rechtliche frage ob das
kriegshandlungen sind oder nicht fix hat
jung sehen ist meines erachtens geklärt
obwohl es da waren juristen
unterschiedliche auffassungen gibt die
einheitliche betrachtung ist dass das
keine teilnahme am krieg ist vielen dank
für das gespräch herr
vorne
neben der militärischen gewalt gibt es
noch ein weiteres druckmittel die
abhängigkeit von russischer energie
neben öl geht es vor allem um erdgas in
deutschland ist zur hälfte davon
abhängig viele osteuropäische staaten
auch gas ist besonders für wärme wichtig
in deutschland wird jede zweite wohnung
damit beheizt doch wie lange wird
russisches erdgas noch nach europa
gepumpt und zu welchem preis kann
deutschland im schlimmsten fall auf
russisches gas verzichten thaddäus
parade
hier im stade an der elbe liegt sie die
hoffnung hier könnte einer von drei
flüssiggas terminals in deutschland
entstehen pressetermin des
niedersächsischen wirtschaftsministers
vor wenigen tagen die pläne für das
terminal liegen seit jahren in der
schublade doch erst jetzt mit möglichen
gaslieferstopps aus russland kommt das
projekt in fahrt ich glaube start ist am
weitesten vorangeschritten von allen
drei vergleichbaren potenziellen
standorten glaube dass wir noch in
diesem frühjahr vielleicht sogar bis
ostern ein antrag auf planfeststellung
haben für die dringend benötigten
weltweiten flüssiggas importe kommt das
terminal allerdings viel zu spät jetzt
rächt sich dass deutschland anders als
seine nachbarn bislang vollauf russische
gas pipelines gesetzt hat unsere
abhängigkeit ist der auch nach 2014 nach
dem krim konflikt noch weiter nach oben
gegangen und das zu einem zeitpunkt wo
wir bereits 2010 eine gemeinsame gas
diversifizierungsstrategie in der eu mit
deutscher unterschrift verabschiedet
haben die ganz klar sagte wir müssen die
abhängigkeit von russland reduzieren die
zeit drängt denn deutschlands
gasspeicher sind nur noch zu einem
drittel gefüllt vor dem nächsten winter
sollte der füllstand mindestens 80
prozent betragen denn gasspeicher sind
das rückgrat der deutschen gasversorgung
sie dienen als puffer decken den
gasverbrauch in der kalten jahreszeit
und verhindern so versorgungsengpässe um
das befüllen der speicher hat sich die
bundesregierung bislang nicht gekümmert
das hat sie den großen energiekonzernen
überlassen pikant rund ein viertel der
deutschen gasspeicher wird vom
russischen gazprom konzern kontrolliert
und diese speicher sind besonders leer
das heißt wir übertragen die
verantwortung für das wichtigste
instrument der deutschen gasversorgung
sicherheit einem staatskonzern eines
autoritären staates das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium will jetzt
eine nationale gasreserve anlegen
energieunternehmen sollen gesetzlich
verpflichtet werden ihre gasspeicher bis
zum winter zu füllen
es ist immer am ende ein öffentliches
gut und dementsprechend muss es immer
auch eine rolle des staates gehen im
idealfall natürlich auch immer zusammen
mit der industrie doch wie befüllen wenn
kein oder kaum noch gas aus russischen
pipelines kommt europäische gas
förderländer wie norwegen oder die
niederlande sind mit ihrer produktion
schon jetzt am limit und nicht nur
deutschland hängt am russischen gas
tropf je weiter der blick richtung osten
geht desto größer auch die abhängigkeit
von russland sollten russlands
gaslieferungen ganz ausbleiben liebe nur
flüssiggas als ersatz es wird den
tankern tiefgekühlt zum zielort
transportiert in einer studie hat die
wissensfabrik beutel aus brüssel
untersucht ob es eu weit möglich wäre
russisches erdgas durch flüssiggas
importe zu ersetzen
die hauptaussage es im endeffekt
60 prozent des gases haben wir sowieso
ohne russisches gas 20 prozent können
wir uns wahrscheinlich noch auf dem
weltmarkt organisieren und die fehlenden
20 prozent müssen dann über nachfrage
reduktion in europa eingespart werden
doch leicht wird der einkauf nicht denn
die liefermengen für flüssiggas sind
begrenzt wichtigsten exporteure sind
australien katar und die vereinigten
staaten größte importeur china japan und
südkorea ein teil der lieferungen müsste
also von asien nach europa umgeleitet
werden das würde viel politisches
handlungsfähiger fordern
zum beispiel zu nennen dass man
tatsächlich mitte mit so fernen ländern
wie japan darüber spricht dass dort
vielleicht mehr kohle verstromt wird
damit erdgas übrig bleibt was dann eben
nicht auf den japanischen markt kommt
sondern vielleicht auf den indischen
markt und damit an katar mehr gas nach
europa schicken kann ein wettlauf mit
der zeit erst vor wenigen tagen hat die
bundesregierung den markt gebietsleiter
thw beauftragt gas für 1,5 milliarden
euro einzukaufen experten warnen jedoch
vor alleingängen
die beschaffungsstrategie muss unbedingt
europäisch sein das macht überhaupt
keinen sinn dass das frankreich und
deutschland und polen auf dem globalen
markt miteinander wetteifern wenn wir
uns gegenseitig die preise nach oben
treiben dann bezahlen wir alle nur den
den exporteuren mehr geld ohne dass
dafür unbedingt mehr energie bei uns
ankommt das flüssiggas terminal den
stadl könnte frühestens 2026 in betrieb
gehen mit blick auf den nächsten winter
bedeutete das für deutschlands und
europas gasversorgung viel unsicherheit
und viel improvisation
in berlin begrüße ich die
wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin claudia
kempfert guten abend gute namentlich
größe können wir russisches gas
vollständig ersetzen ja das können wir
schon es ist nicht leicht in der tat
müssen wir uns da europäisch absprechen
über flüssiggas der lieferungen die
kapazitäten ausweiten aber auch aus
anderen pipeline routen beispielsweise
auch aus nordafrika mehr gas beziehen
und es wird darauf ankommen dass wir
auch mehr gas einsparen
und wenn uns das gelingt jetzt gerade
auch über den sommer tatsächlich auch
die speicher aufzufüllen auch
vollständig aufzufüllen da kommen wir
auch gut über den nächsten winter wir
erleben jetzt schon einen preisschock
nach dem anderen wird energie so zum
luxusgut
fossile energie drohte zum luxusgut zu
werden erneuerbare energien werden ja
immer billiger hier kommt es darauf an
dass wir alles dafür tun um energie
einzusparen
gerade im gebäudebereich mehr wärme
pumpen einzusetzen und auch alles dafür
tun dass energetisch saniert wird wenn
wir nach öl ansprechen auch dass wir da
auf elektromobilität umstellt und
möglichst schnell weg kommen von der
fossilen energie dass es auf jeden fall
preiswerter und damit wir das zu
schaffen müssen eben auch
einkommensschwachen haushalten
entsprechend geholfen werden in der
zwischenzeit damit eben dieses fossile
luxusgut auch bezahlbar bleibt da würde
ich gerne mal nachfragen der staat
verdient ja in der tat bei diesen hohen
preisen kräftig mit über höhere
steuereinnahmen müsste der verbraucher
da nicht jetzt schon entlastet werden ja
das problem ist einfach wenn wir die
steuern einfach senken ist das keine
garantie dass die preise tatsächlich
sinken werden weil häufig die margen
trotzdem erhöht werden so dass es
sinnvoller ist dass wir die
steuereinnahmen lieber zielgerichtet
einsetzen über auch entlastung für
einkommensschwache haushalte über die
förderung der energetischen
gebäudesanierung
wärmepumpen programm ist hier zu nennen
die ladeinfrastruktur muss ausgebaut
werden also der ist ja viel bedarf da
dass man da auch entsprechend
zielgerichtet das geld einsetzt was ist
dann grundsätzlich jetzt der richtige
weg schneller auf erneuerbare energie
setzen oder kohle und kernkraftwerke
doch noch länger weiter zu betreiben
also eindeutig schneller die
erneuerbaren energien ausbauen wir
brauchen einen booster programme für die
erneuerbaren energien plus energie
sparen also je weniger energie wir
verbrauchen desto besser gerade im
wärmebereich auch in der industrie und
eben auch in allen segmenten und das ist
sehr zentral und die erneuerbaren
energien wirken preissenkend je
schneller wir bekommen von der fossilen
energie desto besser vielen dank für
diese informationen nach berlin danke
ihnen
klar ist dass der krieg stand jetzt
rückwirkungen auch auf uns hat das
merken die verbraucher in deutschland
längst nicht nur an der tankstelle so
ziemlich alle es wird zum teil deutlich
teurer
ein problem vor allem für die die
ohnehin schon jeden euro zweimal
umdrehen müssen
drei euro 99 kostet ein halbes kilo
tomaten im supermarkt momentan 10 bio
eier
449 butter 2 eur 59 vieles wird teurer
das beobachten auch die statistischen
landesämter
jeden monat erheben sie 30.000
einzelpreise von waren und
dienstleistungen so stark wie derzeit
stiegen die preise seit jahren nicht
meint leo krüll vom statistischen
landesamt nordrhein westfalen abgefüllt
von den energiepreisen wo insbesondere
heizöl ich glaube über 40 prozent teurer
ist als vor einem jahr er hat auch bei
einzelnen lebensmittel stärkere
veränderungen gegeben zum beispiel
margarine und
ist um über 20 prozent teurer aber auch
butter
kein wunder also dass das auch die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher zu
spüren bekommen ein unterhemd für 19
euro
das alles so teuer geworden ist das
manchmal überhaupt jetzt mit tischen
wolf kommen man macht sich mehr gedanken
ob man wirklich braucht oder nicht die
inflation ist zurück und jetzt auch noch
der ukraine krieg und seine konsequenzen
der bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
milliarden euro ausstatten
100 milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
heißt 100 milliarden euro neue schulden
doch die sind schon jetzt auf rekordhöhe
400 milliarden euro wegen der korona
pandemie 60 milliarden als sonder etat
für den klimafonds und jetzt auch noch
das sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
noch nie hatte deutschland höhere
schuldenberge
[Musik]
doch wie viele schulden kann oder darf
ein land sich überhaupt leisten für die
eu liegt dass der maastricht vertrag
fest danach darf die gesamtverschuldung
eines staates maximal 60 prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts betragen aktuell
liegt dieser wert bei vielen eu-staaten
deutlich höher deutschland schneidet
noch vergleichsweise gut ab
also kein grund zur sorge
finanzexperten warnen vor einer politik
auf pump
hohe schulden von staaten werden dann
gefährlich wenn sie durch die
zentralbank durch das drucken von geld
finanziert werden eine solche politik
auf pump die können sie so lange
betreiben
bis die inflation in schwung kommt das
sehen wir gerade
um die inflationswelle zu brechen müsste
die europäische zentralbank eigentlich
die zinsen anheben ob das passiert eher
unwahrscheinlich die verschuldung ist
viel zu hoch wenn sie die zinsen erhöhen
kommen viele schulden
zahlungsschwierigkeiten insbesondere die
hoch verschuldeten staaten und darunter
insbesondere die ganz hoch verschuldeten
staaten im euroraum inflation oder
staatsbankrott die ezb steht vor einem
dilemma ein dilemma das auch die
bevölkerung trifft denn bei steigenden
preisen müssten nun eigentlich auf die
gehälter folgen tun sie aber nicht die
industriegewerkschaft bergbau chemie und
energie fordert darum lohnerhöhungen das
macht sich natürlich bemerkbar wenn die
preissteigerung oberhalb der
lohnsteigerung liegen dann ist das real
kaufkraftverlust und deswegen drängen
wir in diesem jahr darauf dass die
kaufkraft gestärkt wird und ich
kaufkraft verloren geht wir streben
einen kaufkraft plus an also ein
abschluss oberhalb der inflationsrate
eine mögliche folge dieser förderungen
die von ökonomen gefürchteten lohn preis
spirale die forderung nach höheren
löhnen ist absolut verständlich auf der
anderen seite muss man natürlich auch
sehen dass höhere löhne höhere kosten
bedeuten die die unternehmen wieder in
die preise überwälzen und in diesem
prozess der lohnerhöhungen der
preiserhöhung kommt dann die inflation
zum laufen schon jetzt beträgt diese
offiziell 5,1 prozent die milliarden
schulden aus der pandemie der klimafonds
und nun der bundeswehr etat könnten die
inflation noch weiter anheizen wie
finanzminister lindner die gewaltigen
schuldenberge finanzieren möchte ist
derzeit noch unklar
und eben diesen bundesfinanzminister
begrüße ich jetzt in berlin guten abend
herr lindner
hallo schönen guten abend
100 milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
jetzt noch 200 milliarden für die
energiewende bis 2026 wo soll das geld
herkommen
das geld werden wir nur gemeinsam
aufbringen können die voraussetzung
dafür dass wir unsere äußere sicherheit
finanzieren die voraussetzung dafür dass
wir die erneuerung unserer wirtschaft
die aufstellung einer klimaneutralen
volkswirtschaft realisieren das ist ein
starkes wirtschaftliches fundament
wir brauchen gesunde betriebe wir
brauchen beschäftigte die auch gerne die
überstunden leisten weil es sich für sie
individuell lohnt nur wenn wir
wirtschaftliche prosperität und wachstum
haben wirtschaftliche stärke haben dann
kann unser land gewissermaßen aus diesen
schulden herauswachsen droht uns denn
jetzt eine hohe inflation bei
gleichzeitig kriegsbedingt nachlassen
der wirtschaftsleistung
die wirtschaftlichen risiken sind enorm
gewachsen wir hatten ja gehofft dass wir
jetzt langsam in die erholung nach der
pandemie eintreten könnten nun haben wir
diesen grauenvollen krieg in der ukraine
und die damit verbundenen und
notwendigen sanktionen die haben
negative auswirkungen auf uns das sehen
wir alle bei den energiekosten das sehen
wir bei den spritpreisen wenn wir tanken
wir tun das uns mögliche es wird ein
entlastungspaket geben die sogenannte
eeg-umlage auf die stromrechnung
entfällt ab dem ersten siebten der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag und der
steuerliche grundfreibetrag
schlage ich vor zu erhöhen das sind
entlastungen für die menschen und die
leisten einen beitrag dazu dass die
preisentwicklungen für die menschen
verkraftbar sind nun treffen die
wirtschaftlichen folgen dieses krieges
ja nicht nur deutschland was kann denn
die europäische zentralbank zur
stabilisierung tun
die notenbank ist unabhängig das wissen
sie und das ist ja auch die tradition
der deutschen bundesbank das wollte
deutschland immer so haben dass die
zentralbank keine empfehlungen der
politik entgegennimmt oder gar aufträge
ausführt ich nehme allerdings war dass
die europäische zentralbank ja bereits
angekündigt hat ihr
anleihe-ankaufprogramm in diesem jahr zu
modifizieren es ist auch schon von
zinsschritten in diesem jahr von
einzelnen notenbankern die rede gewesen
das heißt wir sehen dass die europäische
zentralbank sich auf dieses
inflationsrisiko einstellt und das halte
ich auch für absolut richtig als
bundesregierung müssen mehr und wollen
wir etwas zweites tun wenn ich das kurz
noch ergänzen darf insbesondere über die
energiepreise wird die inflation
getrieben
wir sind sehr stark abhängig von
russland und große verunsicherungen sind
im markt und deshalb müssen wir unsere
lieferquellen nach deutschland breiter
aufstellen wir brauchen andere quellen
und wir müssen auch neue unsere energie
konzeption überdenken alles auf die
brückentechnologie gas auszurichten das
ist in der aktuellen lage einen neuen
gedanken an neue prüfung wert vielen
dank für das gespräch nach berlin
bitteschön
in den nordwestlichen vororten kers hat
es heftige zerstörungen schon am
wochenende und auch heute gegeben sehr
viele menschen sind unter größten
gefahren von dort geflohen einige die
geblieben sind schicken beunruhigende
handyvideos von soldaten die sich
zwischen den häusern postieren steht ein
häuserkampf bevor gert anhalt
statt sirenengeheul erklingt heute die
ukrainische hymne über dem majdan platz
in kiew
verschwinden werden unsere feinde wie
tau in der sonne heißt es darin
hoffnungsvoll aber die feinde sie
verschwinden nicht sondern sie sammeln
ihre panzertruppen für den lange
erwarteten angriff auf die hauptstadt
und sie wollen der welt mit diesen
bildern ihre übermacht beweisen
und auch diese bilder von kampfjets
veröffentlichten die russen die
maschinen sind im einsatz so steht es im
begleittext des russischen
verteidigungsministeriums um ziele der
militärischen infrastruktur
unter feuer zu nehmen
die propaganda bilder der russen zeigen
freilich nicht wie ihre raketen terror
und zerstörung in die wohngebiete der
großstädte tragen zum beispiel in die
ostukrainische stadt kramer thorsten
bezirk don jetzt wo nach einem
raketeneinschlag zwei tote und sechs
verletzte zu beklagen sind wie der
bürgermeister erklärt
juni die angreifer haben und in der
nacht mit einer luft boden rakete
beschossen dabei wurden eine schule und
ein kindergarten beschädigt eine zweite
rakete traf uns am nachmittag
es werden nun mit raketen auch städte
tief im ukrainischen kernland attackiert
die bisher noch relativ sicher schienen
bila zerkwa 100 kilometer südlich von
kiew meldete seinen ersten angriff die
krater auch hier weit weg von
militäreinrichtungen und mitten im
wohngebiet
der vormarsch der panzer und
truppentransporter kommt immer wieder
ins stocken logistische lücken und
ukrainische gegenwehr halten die
kolonnen auf die raketen aber kommen
überall durch
auch wenn es der ukrainischen luftabwehr
offenbar gelingt feindliche jäger
abzuschießen die übermacht der angreifer
ist erdrückend inzwischen wurden laut us
militär über 600 raketen auf die ukraine
abgefeuert so auch auf die stadt venezia
deren flughafen gestern bereits im
fadenkreuz der marschflugkörper lag und
von dem wie auf den videoaufnahmen der
örtlichen feuerwehr zu sehen ist am ende
des tages nicht mehr viel übrig war nur
rauchende trümmer
[Applaus]
auch in mir pro der viertgrößten stadt
der ukraine bereitet man sich vor in
sowjetzeiten zentrum der waffenindustrie
verschanzt sich die millionenstadt heute
so gut es geht hinter sandsäcken panzer
barrikaden und dem glauben an das
vaterland
den auch er verkörpert präsident
zielinski der nicht müde wird vom westen
noch mehr hilfe und noch härtere
sanktionen gegen moskau zu fordern
die internationale gemeinschaft muss
entschlossener handeln im ringen mit
einem irren muss man alle furcht ablegen
und kommerzielle bedenken über bord
werfen starten und unternehmen müssen
nun moral zeigen denn wir kämpfen gegen
die macht der unmenschlichkeit die
nichts anderes im sinn hat als die
menschheit zu zerstören
manche vergleichen den präsidenten schon
mit dem britischen premier winston
churchill der seine landsleute im
zweiten weltkrieg siegreich gegen
hitlers armeen führte niemals aufgeben
war sein schlachtruf und auch kiews
bürgermeister zeigt einen eisernen
durchhaltewillen
wir werden uns aus kiew nicht verjagen
lassen wir werden wenn es nötig ist jede
straße jedes haus jeden posten mit
unserem leben verteidigen
keiner will sterben aber wir sind dazu
bereit um unsere kinder und unsere
familien zu schützen
anmut und opfer will scheint es den
ukrainern aller berufe und altersgruppen
weiterhin nicht zu mangeln
viele meiner freunde haben sich
freiwillig zu den waffen gemeldet und
darum gebeten an die front geschickt zu
werden meine pflicht ist es für mein
land zu arbeiten und die soldaten zu
unterstützen
deswegen bin ich hier und ich bin sehr
stolz darauf
die angriffe der russischen bodentruppen
konzentrieren sich vor allem auf die
nord westlichen vororte kiews wie ihre
pin das am wochenende zum schlachtfeld
wurde und dessen zivilbevölkerung unter
größten gefahren vor den invasoren
flüchtete
der letzte halbwegs gangbare weg in
sicherheit führt durch die ruinen einer
von den verteidigern gesprengten brücken
die zurückblieben schickten alarmierende
handyvideos von soldaten die sich
zwischen den wohnblocks postieren und
offenbar vorbereiten für den häuserkampf
die bilder die im internet aus dem seit
kriegsbeginn und kämpften kharkiv
kursieren geben anlass zu den
schlimmsten befürchtungen
militärexperten meinen inzwischen dass
putin in der ukraine dieselben
verheerungen anrichten lässt wie in
grosny oder alle buch
so lange der weg nach rumänien noch
offen ist schicken sie die kleinen und
die schwachen auf die reise in
sicherheit die jüdische gemeinde von
odessa hat pogrome der zarenzeit und den
horror des holocaust überstanden jetzt
droht neue gefahr ihre familie wurde von
den deutschen ermordet nun muss maya vor
den russen fliehen mit 91 jahren
ja was für ein schicksal ich bin jetzt
hier in der sendezentrale mainz
verbunden mit unserem russland
korrespondenten axel sturm axel haben
wir es bei den entscheidungen die im
kreml getroffen werden mit einsamen
entscheidungen eines faktisch allein
regierenden präsidenten zu tun
na ja wir haben es mit einem staatschef
mit einem präsidenten zu tun der in die
selbst gewählte isolation gezogen ist
das berichten einhellig experten die
dieses regime und diesen politiker seit
vielen vielen jahren beobachten die
biografen streiten darüber was denn so
der zeitpunkt gewesen sein muss an dem
sich wladimir putin zurückgezogen hat
und während er das tat immer mehr macht
in seinen händen konzentriert hat die
einhellige meinung ist eigentlich dass
es um das jahr 2011 herum gewesen sein
muss denn damals gab es die bislang
größten proteste seiner amtszeit nach
den parlamentswahlen in russland bei
denen er die narros ihr wieder haushoch
gewonnen hat zwar mit verlusten aber
haushoch geworden hat aber die menschen
sind auf die straße gegangen
hunderttausende sie haben
wahlfälschungen angeprangert und man
glaubt dass das der zeitpunkt war wo
putin möglicherweise den dass anfang vom
ende erahnen konnte und sich
zurückgezogen hat da würde ich gerne
nachfragen die unterstützung für putin
in der eigenen bevölkerung war lange
zeit ja groß wie verändert der krieg
gegen die ukraine die stimmung in
russland selbst
die unterstützung war groß weil putin
für russland und fiel für die russischen
für die russische bevölkerung getan hat
er hat die wirtschaft vorangetrieben er
hat dafür gesorgt dass russland mit
seinen erdgas und erdöl produkten viel
geld verdient hat er hat den
lebensstandard gehoben und jetzt ist es
natürlich noch zu früh am 12 kriegstag
so etwas wie ein meinungsbild ab zu
fragen wie hat sich die stimmung
verändert aber man muss konstatieren
dass jeden tag in russland in diesen
tagen menschen so mutig sind und auf die
straße gehen trotz der drakonischen
strafen die wir im laufe des vergangenen
jahres immer wieder beobachten konnten
in unserer berichterstattung auch schon
während der navalny proteste sind heute
immer noch hunderte tausende von
menschen bereit dieses risiko einzugehen
und auch die straße zu gehen während im
russischen staatsfernsehen die
propaganda maschine läuft und ein ganz
anderes bild zeichnet vielen dank für
diese einschätzungen
auch heute haben wir wieder stimmen von
menschen aus der ukraine für sie
zusammengestellt die von uns
ausgezeichneten skype gespräche und die
handy videos die uns erreichen zeigen
sehr authentisch wie sich der krieg über
den alltag liegt nichts ist wie zuvor
heute war ein sehr schlimmer tag ich bin
eigentlich aus kiew dort gab es heute
die schwersten kämpfe seit kriegsbeginn
ich habe erfahren dass der bürgermeister
von hommel getötet wurde er wurde
erschossen als er dabei war lebensmittel
und medikamente zu verteilen
zwei enge mitarbeiter von ihm nicht
persönlich kannte wurden dabei auch
getötet das ist sehr schwer für mich zu
ertragen
in friedlichen zeiten arbeite ich in der
import abteilung eines der größten
einzelhandelsunternehmen in der ukraine
da bin ich für den einkauf von waren aus
der ganzen welt zuständig
[Musik]
und jetzt haben wir uns natürlich neu
orientiert und ich koordiniere
hilfsleistungen aus verschiedenen
ländern
[Musik]
genaue information was passiert und
unglaublich dass die leute
im moment planen wir nicht groß voraus
für tage sondern höchstens von stunde zu
stunde
ich weiß eigentlich nur dass mein freund
und ich jetzt gleich etwas gemeinsam
essen werden und wir dann in die stadt
gehen wollen um ein paar sachen für das
haus zu besorgen indem wir jetzt sind
macht sondern um 1 startet dann muss ich
bis 18 uhr bis 20 uhr schon zu meinen
arbeit kommen und hier bleiben
unbeachtet und dann
machen mehrere leute wohnen auch an die
arbeit und die fahre ich nach hause und
die bleiben da man sie machen ihre
arbeit war dass es wichtig ist wenn wir
unter schlaf- und dass dann kein problem
dann schaffen wir ganze nacht durch und
egal ob will kommt danach
genaugenommen mussten wir jetzt schon
dreimal fiel gleich am ersten tag aus
kiew nach der pin wo mein freund her ist
dort mussten wir dann auch weg weil die
russischen truppen in die stadt
eingedrungen sind dann sind wir weiter
nach wie nizza und von dort mussten wir
auch wieder fliehen und jetzt sind wir
in die vip und hoffentlich kommt der
krieg nicht auch hierher
ja das ist die hoffnung in der ukraine
informiert uns tag für tag meine
kollegin katrin eigendorf über die
aktuellen entwicklungen
sie berichtet dass dem westen der
ukraine rund 280 kilometer luftlinie
entfernt von der hauptstadt kiew
kathrin wir haben sie den heutigen tag
erlebt wie verändern sich die lage und
die stimmung
also die stimmung wird immer bitterer
mit jedem tag den dieser krieg dauert
und auch mit jeder verhandlung die
geführt wird im prinzip glaubt hier
niemand mehr dass man auch
verhandlungsweg irgendeinen erfolg mit
putin erzielen kann und wir haben uns
heute mit menschen hier mit
verschiedenen menschen darüber
unterhalten und auch mit politikern habe
ich darüber gesprochen was gibt es
eigentlich überhaupt noch für eine
perspektive mit putin zu irgend einer
einigung zu kommen und sei es auch nur
auf dem kleinsten nenner und es haben ja
auch heute wieder verhandlungen
stattgefunden und die ukraine sehen dass
putin ihr vorschlägt und mit welchen
forderungen er in diese verhandlungen
reingeht eigentlich als sehr sehr
zynisch denn was er fordert ist eine
komplette kapitulation dieser regierung
er hat sich ja eigentlich von seinem
narrativ nicht verabschiedet dass er
hier faschisten an der macht sieht und
glaubt die bevölkerung dieses landes von
dieser faschistischen regierung befreien
zu wollen nur so kann man hier erklären
dass er den menschen hier tatsächlich
vorschlägt über humanitäre korridore aus
der ukraine nach russland zu gehen wer
will nach russland russland putin hat
das ukrainische volk komplett verloren
ich sehe hier keinen mehr auch menschen
die vorher geschäfte mit russland
gemacht haben auch leute die beziehungen
russische familie haben der ihr noch in
irgendeiner form diesem russischen
präsidenten vertrauen schenkt man setzt
hier wirklich voll auf den westen und
ich höre auch immer wieder von leuten
und diese forderungen die dringt immer
weiter durch der westen muss uns hier
unterstützen ihr müsst unseren luftraum
sichern das ist die einzige form wie man
die ukraine retten kann vielen dank für
diese einschätzung und schilderung
katrin eigendorf
erste station der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer auf der flucht ist für die
allermeisten polen wie kann man den
menschen dort helfen ein pianist aus
deutschland versucht es mit musik herner
hebestreit über den sogenannten piano
man
am grenzübergang amerika treffen
flüchtende aus der ukraine auf helfende
aus polen und der ganzen welt es ist ein
platz zum aufwärmen über die nächsten
schritte der flucht planen kann die
polnischen grenze haben alles im blick
nur ganz selten geraten sie so in rage
ja
was machen sie damit ganz schnell hektar
das ist ein flucht will trägt da ganz
schnell
der mann der die grenze rinn an den rand
des nervenzusammenbruchs bringt es
davide martello italiener aus
deutschland reist mit schwerem gepäck
und in einer noch schwereren mission
meint engine
fcz landest eine friedensbotschaft zu
senden mit der die herzen dieser uralten
politiker öffnen möchte die müssen liebe
und frieden wieder eine chance geben
und dann fängt der mitten in diesem
chaos
einfach an zu spielen
in diesen traurigen tagen schleppt da
wieder sein klavier im grenzgebiet
überall hin wo die menschen froh sind
für ein paar minuten ihr elend zu
vergessen
[Musik]
drei tage so sagt sie sei sie aus der
ukraine unterwegs gewesen ohne dann muss
ich dass man ihren kleinen sohn nach der
englischen vokabel fragen
da wieder hört zu und auch wenn ihm die
kälte manchmal in die finger kriegt
spielt er weiter er will diesen
entwurzelten menschen hoffnung machen
[Musik]
was für eine schöne geste wenn sie den
menschen in der ukraine oder auf der
flucht helfen wollen dann können sie
spenden an das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf.de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
bisher sind auf diesem weg übrigens fast
67 millionen euro an spenden eingegangen
danke an alle die geholfen haben und das
noch tun
die lage in der ukraine hat sich auch
heute nicht verbessert im gegenteil
weiter werden wohngebiete angegriffen
weiter sterben soldaten und zivilisten
am donnerstag soll es erstmals seit
beginn des angriffskrieges gegen die
ganze ukraine ein treffen der
außenminister beider länder in der
türkei geben vermittelt hat dass der
türkische präsident erdogan über
aktuelle entwicklungen können sie sich
jederzeit auf zdf heute informieren und
ab 21 uhr 45 dann im heute journal auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
eine große verheißung der kalte krieg
ist vorbei und ein bitteres erwachen wir
wurden eiskalt